- Hey David!
-Hi!
- Meine Freunde/-innen und ich
sind ganz klar Deine größten Fans.
Du wirst es jetzt vielleicht nicht glauben,
weil wir alle 16 Jahre jung sind,
aber es stimmt.
Also habe ich auch eine Frage an Dich
weil ich gelesen habe dass Du in Norddeutschland,
in einem Ort namens HASSELHOF
ein Stück Land kaufen möchtest,
weil Du denkst Du könntest
dort Verwandte von Dir finden.
Stimmt diese Geschichte?
Denn es klingt für mich etwas eigenartig.
Nun, ich wäre so glücklich wenn Du meine Frage
beantworten würdest und ich finde Dich so toll David.
Wirklich, und - Jap.
Das war meine Frage. Tschüss!
Meine Antwort lautet: Ich fand eine Stadt
namens "HASSELHOFF" in Deutschland.
Und ich wollte dort hingehen und ein
Stück Land kaufen, um dort hinzuziehen.
Weil ich unbedingt wollte, dass meine Anschrift
"David Hasselhof(f) Deutschland" lautet.
Das ist eine sehr einfache
und sehr kurze Adresse.
Jedoch fand ich jetzt heraus,
dass es gar keine Hasselhoffs in HASSELHOF gibt.
Sondern dass sie in VÖLKERSEN leben.
VÖLKERSEN ist bei BREMEN.
Und tatsächlich kam mein
Ur-Ur-Ur-Großvater von dort.
Und ich hab ein Foto,
und ich ging dort hin...
Hasselhoff
HASSEL - HOFF
Hasselhoff kommt von Haselnuss, aus der Zeit
als sie noch einen Haselnuss-Betrieb führten,
und der Haselnuss(stamm)baum geht
zurück bis in das sechzehnte Jahrhundert
und ich habe noch einen Fahrschein von meinem
Ur-Ur-Großvater, Carl Hasselhoff,
der den ganzen Weg von BREMEN nach Baltimore -
Maryland kam, wo er einen Sohn namens
Joseph Hasselhoff hatte
der einen Sohn namens Joseph Hasselhoff hatte,
welcher mein Vater ist.
Und so fanden wir heraus,
dass meine Wurzeln eigentlich in VÖLKERSEN liegen.
Ich weiß nicht mal ob ich das Aussprechen kann.
Aber meine Verwandten sind dort
und ich plane zurück nach VÖLKERSEN zu gehen
und ein wenig Zeit mit meinen Verwandten
zu verbringen,denn es gibt dort Hasselhoffs.
Und danke dass Du auf mich stehst. Ich liebe es
junge Fans zu haben, besonders so süße wie Dich.
Whoo!